Final rule,
that's called pet a cat when you
encounter one on the street and it's.
It's a very.
It's the most personal chapter in the
book.
It's a lot about my daughter and my
daughter was very ill when she was,
when she was a kid,
but particularly when she was a
teenager.
She had a very terrible time of it.
She had juvenile rheumatoid arthritis
and when she was between the ages of 14
and 16 at first destroyed her hip,
which had to be replaced and then it
destroyed the ankle on her other leg
which had to be replaced and she walked
around for two years on broken legs and
she was taking massive doses of opiates
and could hardly stay awake and like.
And she had this advanced auto immune
disease which produced all sorts of
other symptoms that were just as bad as
the joint degeneration but which are
harder to describe.
And so it was just bloody brutal,
you know,
and as a test of your faith,
there's almost nothing that's more
direct than a serious illness inflicted
upon an innocent child.
Right.
And so the chapter is a meditation on
that.
And also on,
well what to do in a situation like that
because everyone is going to have a
situation like that in some sense,
you know,
because you'll be faced with illness in
the people that you love and in crisis.
And so it's a,
it's a practical guide to coping with
those sorts of things.
Like in one of the things you do when
you're overwhelmed by crisis is you
shortened your timeframe.
You know,
it's like you can't think about next
month.
Maybe you can't even bloody well think
about next week or maybe not even
tomorrow.
You know,
because now is just so overwhelming that
that's all there is.
It's like,
and that's what you do.
You cut your timeframe back until you
can cope with it.
And if it's not the next week that you
see how to get through,
then it's the next day.
And if it's not the next day,
then it's the next hour.
And if it's not the next hour,
then it's the next minute.
And you know,
people are very,
very,
very tough.
And it turns out that if you face
things,
it turns out that if you face things
that you can put up with a lot more than
you think you can put up within,
you can do it without becoming
corrupted.
And she did recover quite,
quite fully and much as a consequence of
our own machinations because she figured
out what was wrong with her and then
took the necessary steps to fix it,
which is nothing short of a bloody
miracle as far as I'm concerned.
And anyways,
part of the,
the,
the cat bit is I actually started by
talking about our daughter who actually
died at about a year ago,
but he's still alive in the book.
Um,
I,
you know,
I let people know because dog lovers
love dogs and if you love cats than they
think you don't like dogs and then they
don't like you.
So I also pointed out at the beginning
of the chapter that,
you know,
if you want a pet,
a dog on the street,
that's okay too.
So you don't have to get up in arms
about it.
But.
But the idea is that,
you know,
you have to be alert when you're
suffering,
you have to be alert to the beauty in
life,
the unexpected beauty in life.
And that's kind of what I was trying to
get across with the idea of the cat.
There's this cat that lives across the
street from us called Ginger Ginger's,
Assamese.
Captain Cat's really aren't domesticated
a technically speaking.
They're still wild animals,
but they kind of like people.
God only knows why,
but they do,
you know.
And so ginger will come wandering over
and our dog looks at her,
but their friends and she rolls over on
his back and seek.
We used to noser a bit and then she'd
kind of Mosey over and let you pet her
if she was feeling like that day.
And you know,
you have to look for those little bit of
stuff,
little bit of sparkling crystal in the
darkness.
When things are bad,
you have to look and see where things
are still beautiful and where there's
still something that's sustaining.
No,
you narrow your timeframe and you be
grateful for what you have.
And that can get you through some very
dark times and maybe even successfully
if you're lucky,
but even if unsuccessfully,
that maybe it's only tragic and not
absolute hell,
and you can do that,
you know,
in the worst situation you can make it
only tragic and not held.
And there's a big gap between tragedy
and hell,
you know,
there's nothing worse at a deathbed than
to see the people they're fighting.
The death is bad enough,
but you can take that as terrible as it
is and making into something that's
absolutely unbearable.
And maybe I think,
and this is sort of what I closed the
book with,
is this idea,
is that if we didn't all attempt to make
terrible things even worse than they
are,
then maybe we could tolerate the
terrible things that we have to put up
with in order to exist.
And maybe we could make the world into a
better place,
you know?
And it's what we should be doing and
what we could be doing because we don't
have anything better to do.
And that's what the book is about.
And that's the end of 12 rules for life.
Thanks.